um karma three i know you've been
working on it you've put out man a few
a few videos um
the karma series is you know i think a
important part of your career and your
legacy what
what is the approach to th
this project and and just that series in
general when you know that like
something's going to go in that karma
series like do you approach it
differently
um yeah i feel like it's more uh
me or like more more of me not really
caring
about like the standard sort of you know
oh i need this type of record or i need
this
i just beat me just in my own zone um
working with different producers and
just trying to uh
you know get some give constantly let
people know i could rap
i could i i would what y'all fell in
love with me for from the beginning
yeah i'm always show up with that so i
feel like the karma karma series gives
me opportunity
to um to kind of mix it up you know have
some big records on there but then have
some [ __ ] for the streets
have something for the fans that that's
into that that's into what i do
you know i mean i was